chris and rosie i mean you are quite
unfiltered on your podcast about your
own
yes yes yes
well weirdly we don't actually talk
about us personally having sex because
we haven't twice
because of what people send us in it's
pure smut yeah really the stuff people
send and we are really boring one of our
first ones that we got sent that really
struck a chord with everyone was some
lady wrought in i see a lady
and
because we said he got any questions and
she wrote in and she said i need some
advice because i'm this is the reason
i'm giving my husband his first foursome
this wednesday
wow
our initial thought was wednesday
definitely sounds like a saturday
you can't ever force him on him
i suppose it's easier to park on a
wednesday
that is true
excuse yet they get child kid
maybe
if you're doing a foursome you probably
don't know what day it is
[Music]
you